people they're looking for a explanation
and people say well as artists you don't
have to give an explanation but as a
leader you do yes I think that's right
so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing
Kanye West speaks out defending his
decision to wear a white lives matter
shirt during Paris fashion week I'm just
extremely happy can you tell by my face
the Grammy winner sparked controversy
earlier this week when he sported this
shirt at his easy season 9 presentation
and on Thursday he doubled down on the
messaging during a sit down with Fox
news's Tucker Carlson tonight I do
certain things from a feeling I like I
just I just channeled the energy it just
feels right
it's using
a gut instinct a connection with God
and just Brilliance the rapper also
reveals what his dad Ray West had to say
about the custom shirt which right-wing
pundit Candace Owens also wore black
lives matter released their 990 IRS
filing they collected 80 million dollars
super frustrating but that's a dead end
so my dad is a educated
um ex-black Panther
and he put a text to me today he said
White lives matter
and I said I thought the shirt was
a funny shirt I thought the idea of me
wearing it was funny and I said dad what
do you think it was funny he said just
a black man stating the obvious White
lives matter has been classified by the
Anti-Defamation League as a white
supremacist phrase that originated in
2015 following the start of the black
lives matter Movement we are in a battle
with the media like the majority of the
media has a Godless agenda
and
their jokes are not working this whole
like oh yeah he's crazy and all these
things they don't work several Stars
spoke out after yay sported the shirt
Jaden Smith who was in attendance at the
Yeezy show tweeted that he had to dip
explaining why he walked out quote I
don't care who it is if I don't support
the message I'm out pretty much is what
I'm saying with that meanwhile Diddy
chimed in on the controversy during a
chat with The Breakfast Club Wednesday
praising yay for being a free thinker
before calling the fashion Choice tone
deaf we don't have to condemn Kanye or
cancel him before he doesn't have to go
crazy but at the same time you know
saying you got to be you you gotta
understand like your actions and on
Thursday Adidas revealed in a statement
that its partnership with Kanye is now
under review
Kanye who previously faced criticism
over his support for Donald Trump also
claims he faced death threats for
wearing a make America great again again
hat I started to really feel this need
to express myself on another level when
Trump was running for office and I liked
him well his ex-wife Kim Kardashian and
her mom Kris Jenner allegedly attempted
to censor his political opinions and
every single person in Hollywood told me
like if I said that I like Trump that my
career would be over that my life would
be over
they said stuff like people get killed
for wearing a hat like that they've had
a someone called me last night and said
anybody wearing a white lives matter
shirt is going to be green lit and that
means that they're going to beat him up
if they wear it I'm like you know okay
green like me then
[Music]
foreign